- I sense a little, like, gym sock.
A pretty woman's armpit.
Vacants of feminism.
Do we sound like idiots?
(classical music)
- It smells like dinner with my parents.
- It smells like dinner
with Henry's parents.
- It's a little smokey.
- Yeah. That's a good word for it.
That's really poetic.
- A little smokey.
- This is close to just
grape juice, just Welch's.
- Yeah, I could really
get drunk on this one.
Just keep going.
- It doesn't even taste like wine.
- Because this one is easier to go down,
I feel like it's more expensive.
- Yeah, I'll say like
25 bucks on this one.
- $3.00.
- Walgreen's wine.
- It's $11.99.
- $40.00.
(cash register ringing)
- Oh, (bleep) what?
- Oh, hey Yellowtail, you're
doing something right.
- Yellowtail all day everyday.
- Ooh. Yeah, that's different.
- That smells much more like wine.
- I don't like this one as much.
This one's not as fruity.
- Boo. Boo these wines.
They really taste like
something you'd pour on a cut.
- I would pay good money for this.
- I'm gonna go with $12.00.
- $35.00.
- That feels like a $6.00 TJ's wine.
(cash register ringing)
- (in unison) Aahh!
- This is older than some
people who work here.
- There's a lot cooler things
you can by with 150 bucks,
like probably a used Nintendo DS.
- When you know something's expensive
it tastes way better.
- Ooh, it smells sweeter.
Maybe a little floral?
I'm making that up.
- Everybody makes up words
when they're tasting wine.
- There's like very little bite to it.
- This one I could see myself
spending a little bit more on.
- I would get a glass of this
at TGI Fridays.
- I think this is a Riesling that's
$25.00.
- 30, 40 bucks a bottle.
- I'm gonna say $12.00.
- Is it Barefoot?
It's Barefoot!
Barefoot Chardonnay?
(cash register ringing)
- I love Barefoot.
Why are you hating on all the cheap--
Just because they come at a good price.
This is why you're not Asian.
- I'm not hating.
- I (bleep) knew it.
I (bleep knew it)
- [Man] $4.50?
- Mmm. Yeah, this is really good.
- This is pinot noir.
Yes, hello friend.
- Is it wrong for me to
say that it's kind of sexy?
- I think there is a hint of
both fruit and oak to them.
- Fruit and oak, fruit and oak,
it's always fruit and oak with you.
- Yeah. That's wine talk.
- I think it tastes like tree leaves.
I'm gonna say it's $3.00.
- $30.00.
- $22.00.
- 50.
- $50.00.
- Whoa.
(cash register ringing)
- Aaahhh!
- Hey!
(bleep) yeah!
I'm so (bleep) classy, you guys.
Ugh, I am just a classy bitch.
- How can you possibly say that
when you're sitting here with purple hair?
- Hey!
- I just really don't know wine.
I drink it every day,
and obviously cannot
tell one from the other.
- Who gives a (bleep).
Just drink some wine with your
spaghetti, you dumb idiot.
- If you like it, you like it.
- Garrett, we (bleep) nailed this test.
- You did pretty well.
- We nailed it.
People think I'm all edgy,
but I'm also classy as (bleep).
- [Garrett] Sorry, can I take a step back?
I don't think anybody has ever said,
"classy as (bleep)," has been classy.